there's a story here from breitbart
blagojevich democrats very fearful of
what i know ex-democrat illinois
governor turned trumpcrat rad begovid
said he believes governor jb
pritzker tried to keep him in jail
because democrat establishment's afraid
of what he knows and what he will say
soon the ex-governor blasted pritzker
for reportedly calling trump not once
but twice requesting to keep him behind
bars jb called trump not once but twice
joining with the most republicans to say
keep him in don't let him out keep him
in don't let him out why did he do it
bolgovich continued before foreshadowing
his willingness to expose the under
belly of his former party i truly
believe it's because jb pritzker
governor pritzker and some of the
democratic political establishment is
very fearful they they're very fearful
what i know and what i can say and what
i'm likely to say and what i will say
soon that's why i think
that he did that so what is it that you
know that they're afraid of well there's
a lot of things a lot of them are on the
tapes and that's one of the reasons why
those tapes are under seal so a lot of
the stuff that's on those tapes i can't
speak about except for the ones that
have been released
some of them actually illegally the
chicago tribune was able to get tapes
notwithstanding the court seal and the
republican candidate for governor
used them against jb pritzker and our
governor in the race his race for
governor back in 2018
pritzker pritzker's on the phone he
called me up and asked me to make him
united state senator so he's on the very
calls
that uh you know ended up
sending me where i went
and
i politely had full discussions with him
about his aspirations to be a senator
told him it was unlikely that i'd pick
him had a good relationship with him
back then he asked me then if i could he
was shopping around for an office if i
could make him state treasurer because i
had the power to do that too and he
anticipated the vacancy of the trade
state treasurer's office i told him that
he had a better chance of me doing that
for him than the united states senate
nothing
illegal about these conversations but
within the conversation he was referring
to you know my desire to appoint a black
person to the senate as being a
political a problem my black problem he
called it which almost
indicates
certainly some insensitivity about race
and if you're these neo-race these
neo-racists
keep pointing to their fingers at
everything being racist i mean he'd
certainly be one of their poster childs
wouldn't he for saying that i'm not
saying he is i'm just saying he said it
but i had a good relationship with him i
had pointed him uh
he had supported my opponent in the
democratic primary for governor 2002 but
then when i won he asked me if i'd make
him the director of the illinois human
rights commission and i did and as far
as i know he did a good job and then
when calamity came after he made those
phone calls that phone call to me and we
talked politely
i understood that he was stayed awake
because everybody did and they were
right to do it because when you have
what you i have that's leprosy nobody
wants to come near that that's lest they
catch it
but then when i'd been in prison for all
those years
and uh
trump was had publicly said that he was
going to let me out indicated he was
letting me out he called my wife patty
in july
of 2020 or 2019 that he was going to do
it
this was a little bit before his call on
that ukrainian phone call right
the five republican congressman
wrote president trump a letter saying
don't let him out and pritzker called
trump twice
urging him not to do it and you know if
he wants to say publicly keep him as a
corrupt son of a [ __ ] and all the rest
i get the politics of that i don't like
it but i get it but you go the extra
mile to actually call the president and
try to keep him
to keep me in prison when i have young
children like he has and i'd already
been in prison for seven and a half
years why would he do that
i think because of the political fears
that they have on the things that i
could do and say that would expose them
some of that on those fbi tapes i think
governor you you seem like you're in
pretty good shape right now yeah okay
i'm not better shaped than governor
that's my question actually have you
seen a picture of what governor pritzker
looks like let's take a look um so my
question to you as they pull up his
picture
it seems like you're a fighter you've
mentioned that you're a golden gloves
boxer
um pritzker doesn't seem to be working
out as much as you uh my question is
this politically
if you were to fight him who would win
and then if you actually stepped in a
ring with governor pritzker who would
win that fight
well i may be a no-brainer right that'd
be no contest
hillary would be a tougher fight than
him
you think you'd knock him out what are
you saying go right to the god blast him
i'd go right to the body yeah right he'd
bend over
that's unfortunate you know i wonder why
that is with him i mean he was
inherited a lot of money to hide hotel i
said yeah the hyatt family pittsburgh
family i'm well aware who they are i say
things i shouldn't say and i'm going to
say it again i know this is wrong
because i shouldn't make fun of the fact
that he's we have a chubby governor
rotund
beyond rotund
but he was born with a silver silver
ladle in his mouth and
and that's not right and the reason i
say it is because of what he did when he
called trump to keep me in otherwise
i wouldn't make fun of him like that but
if i step away and try to be
good as i should try to be
i feel bad for him that that can't be
good he shouldn't be like that he should
spend all that money and time to
you know
take a walk and do it consistently it's
not good for his health and i think the
stress of the office is is partly
causing that yeah i think and
politically how do you think you would
match up against him let's say you could
run again for governor i assume he's
going to run again for re-election yeah
how would you fare against him in a
democratic primary sure
i think i could be really competitive i
really do now he's got you know he spent
170 million dollars of his own money
that he inherited
to win governor the first time 170 or
175 million by the way if i was going to
sell a senate seat isn't he my guy
i mean this is the guy he would have
bought it because he wanted to be
something he asked me to make him
senator then he asked me to make him
treasury he just wanted to be something
and uh if i was what they said i was
this is my guy i could have you know
given him a discount 30 million i will
say that he is giving you a run on a the
great head of hair campaign both of you
governor former governors
killing it in the hair game what do you
say to that
yeah good i mean look i missed the old
jb that i used to know and like i mean i
never realized he was has that mean
streak that he has and by the way he's
been a terrible governor too and the way
he's mishandled the covet situation he's
politicized that
and uh
in such a way where people in illinois
don't trust him
and it's not unlike some of the other
governors too they
they don't practice what they preach
they're big hypocrites and they don't
lead by example or join in the shared
sacrifice and when you're asking people
to make sacrifices you should be the
first one making those sacrifices so if
you enjoyed this little short segment
from the podcast that we did here's
another short segment to watch or if you
want to see the entire podcast click
over here take care everybody bye-bye
[Music]